[Music]
here's your money briefing for Monday
March 6th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
people who manage their bank account or
trade stocks with investment apps are
adding software to discourage them from
making impulsive decisions with their
money Wall Street Journal personal
finance reporter Amani mauis joins us to
talk about the programs and how they
allow people to take a digital pause
Imani thanks so much for being with us
thanks for having me so Amani this type
of software sounds familiar where have
we seen this before I think this kind of
software became really popular to
address social media addiction people
who kind of were finding they were
spending hours and hours maybe scrolling
through Instagram or Twitter when they
felt they could better use that time
doing other things so how is that
adapted into people's personal finances
I think as more of Our Lives is being
managed on our phones a lot of the app
apps or programs that we're using
they're designed to be really really
engaging so whether or not it's keeping
tabs on what the market is doing just
the ability to know at any time of day
whether your portfolio is up or down
that can be really addicting or checking
internet forums to see if you can get
tips that will maybe give you an edge in
the stock market all of these things
kind of provide a thrill and having it
in the palm of your hand makes it hard
to turn off sometimes so what some
people have started to do after
realizing that they may have a problem
and they want to spend less time on
these apps is they force themselves to
take a break up to 20 seconds just to
calm themselves down and say what's my
intention here what is it that I want to
be doing and the way it works it's a
third party app there's a few apps that
do this is you install it and then you
say hey every time I open whether or not
it's a brokerage like Robin Hood or coin
stats which is a forum it interrupts
that process and says take a deep breath
what's your intention in using this app
and then you either learn to hate the
app because it's getting in the way of
what you want to do or you kind of train
yourself to stop using that app as much
so what are some examples of this type
of software so one app that's really
popular is called one sec so that's the
app that actually works with your iPhone
to interrupt that process and it has a
few options so either it asks you to
take a deep breath or it opens up your
front camera and forces you to look at
yourself so that you could confront what
it is that you're about to do and you
could even set it up to direct you to
different things whether it's directing
you to a podcast that you like to listen
to or maybe a news app where you could
consume more curated content or even
just telling you to take a walk wow so
the software wants the person to just
take a look at themselves it's almost
like it wants the person to guilt
themselves into making a better decision
absolutely I actually downloaded it and
it's really funny because when you're
opening up your app it's always at that
super unflattering angle and you're kind
of forced to look at yourself in this
state and reevaluate whatever it is that
you're about to do wow now you mentioned
a 20-second time period a moment ago
what's the significance of 20 seconds so
I think 20 seconds it doesn't sound like
it's that long but in smartphone time
it's forever because we're so used to
getting things instantly opening an app
tapping a message and having it
automatically appear so once you're
slowing down that process it kind of
forces the other part of your brain to
kick in so I talked to some
researchers and psychologists that say
when we open our smartphone the
automatic side of our brain kicks in so
it's not an active decision making
process we're more passively consuming
whatever is on the phone but once you
slow down it allows the other side of
your brain that's responsible for
critical thinking and more thorough
decision making to take over and
reevaluate but what does the software
mean for the financial apps you know in
a lot of cases their business model is
based on people making all these
transactions buying and selling stocks
adding to a savings account adding to a
checking account and if there's this
interference being run between the user
and the financial app what does that
mean for the financial apps business
I think on the surface it's easy to say
it's bad for the business model right
because you're seeing these customers
kind of retaliate against the design
choices that maybe reward risk your
behavior or more active use however
based on some consultants in the
industry that I was speaking to that
mindset is starting to change and more
companies are starting to realize that
what you really want to kind of induce
with your design or encourage with your
product design is sustainable Behavior
instead of just maximal Behavior because
when you go for the maximal behavior
your customers can end up being burnt
out and when they get burnt out they do
things like install third-party apps to
prevent themselves from using your
product which is obviously should be no
company's end goal yeah to be sure the
guard rails can be useful but there are
times when people don't need
interference between them and their
money or making transactions right yeah
I think when you look back at kind of
the way fintech has evolved over the
last decade so so much of it has been
about removing friction removing
guardrails making it faster and I think
with good reason there's no reason why
so much of Commerce in this country
needs to continue to be done on paper
checks right it should be easier it
should be faster payments is one area
where you've seen a lot of innovation
around when it comes to things like
venmo and being able to split a bill at
dinner or quickly pay your babysitter
without having to write a physical check
however According to some research in
the industry when it comes to Big
purchases really important financial
decisions whether that's getting a
mortgage or saving for retirement people
actually prefer
friction they prefer obstacles and they
want that process to be slower and
that's how companies can really build
trust but it's that 20 second delay
enough to Stave off all bad habits when
it comes to accessing money what other
methods could people consider so I think
one of the Consultants that I spoke to
made a really great point and that he
said the people who are downloading
these apps and yes they're increasing in
number but he describe it as still
marginal Behavior because you have to be
very self-aware to realize that you have
a problem and then go research options
to do something about it to then take
that step but they say that marginal
behavior is reflective of a problem that
a lot of people feel so I think
acceptance is the first step but if
you're not ready to accept that you have
a problem you probably just continue
doing that behavior until some sort of
external stimulus come so maybe it's a
loved one that comes in and says hey I
feel like you're being Reckless with our
money if that's your life or your kids
and then that would Inspire that person
to seek help so one of the psychologists
that I spoke to said that she's seen a
meaningful uptick in people seeking
treatment for day trading addiction but
the people seeking treatment they
typically don't come to her until
they're already in crisis and it's
really important for more people to kind
of be aware and stop it before getting
to that point where you want to see a
professional wow you're talking about
addictions you're talking about family
interventions this sounds like it's
pretty serious yeah absolutely and I
think it's just that mindset when we
open our phones that it just feels less
serious like think about writing an
email when you're shooting off a quick
email on your phone maybe you don't
proofread it as carefully or it's a
shorter response but for a really
important email you want to be at your
computer and making that decision so I
think it's really important to realize
that when you're on these apps managing
your money you could be managing your
child's tuition fund or your retirement
savings so you need to make those
decisions with the same
mindset so it's really important to just
take a deep breath and realize just
because you can
make a certain transaction within
seconds doesn't mean that you should and
sometimes you just take a deep breath
and slow down all right that's Wall
Street Journal personal finance reporter
Amani mois Amani thank you so much for
being with us thank you and that's your
money briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the
Wall Street Journal
foreign
[Music]